indelible in the hippocampus is the
laughter the lap the uproarious laughter
between the two and they're having fun
at my expense
dr. Christine Blasi Ford's testimony
last week in which she accused Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh of sexual
assault was a trying moment in the
confirmation process Cavanaugh denied
the accusations and an FBI investigation
did not corroborate those claims but
this week's Time magazine cover story
claims dr. Ford's testimony was a
watershed moment for victims of sexual
abuse saying in part to young men it was
a message that drunken violence could
shadow them all their lives and to
victims Fords testimony was an
invitation to speak up Haley Sweetland
Edwards wrote the cover story and is
here with us to discuss the issue Haley
good morning thank you so much for
having me it's great to have you here
that image on the cover her lasting
impact first of all the image is lasting
but also you write that she is lasting
and making this historic moment right I
think that it's important to remember in
times like this that history isn't
linear and cultural moments don't happen
you know linearly it's you you have
these big moments you have her step
forward and and sort of display the kind
of personal courage that we saw that
doesn't necessarily mean we may see
Breck have and I'll confirm today but
that doesn't necessarily mean that that
was a failure or that we don't we aren't
having an important conversation as a
country that we wouldn't otherwise be
having there was an important comment
that we heard over and over again is
that we believe her and yet we believe
him that this somehow she was mistaken
about who it was that attacked her when
you look at that
do do victims of sexual assault come out
in a better place I think absolutely I
think that you know right now after her
testimony 45 percent of those polled
believed her compared to 33 percent who
believed him which doesn't seem like
maybe that's striking of numbers until
you think about 1991 when Anita Hill
came forward and
almost 60% of Americans believed him
over 24% believed her so we are at a
different moment I mean we are people
are coming forward people are speaking
out you've seen this outpouring of
support and anger at the same time at
this moment there are a lot of women who
are enormous ly disappointed absolutely
I think that you know this kind of goes
back to the first point that these
things don't happen yes step by step
when we look back on you know Rosa Parks
refusing to give up her seat in 1955
nine years later we finally got the
Civil Rights Act but that doesn't negate
her importance or a bad act of personal
bravery that it's a process of change
exactly along the idea though that
victims of sexual assault that they were
heard but are they fully listened to
because I I kept hearing there's not
corroboration of her story rarely is
there ever when there's a sexual assault
so is this still a victory for those
victims to say come and speak out why
should you if you can't corroborate that
story it's a really difficult problem
generally about sexual assault it almost
always happens in a room with another
person another you know maybe a friend
of a person and you know if you think
back on your own life of scary things
that have happened to you who else was
present how would how would you be able
to corroborate those moments and those
are conversations that we need to be
having as men and women in our country
of you know what is acceptable what
where do we set that standard one thing
is for a criminal trial of course you
know for due process and things like
that and their their standards of
evidence and another thing is for job
promotions and and bestowing honors upon
people but either way that they
continues and will for some time I'm
sure Haley we thank you Haley Sweetland
Edwards thank you you